GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Good
morning, everyone.
JUSTIN HAUGH: Hi guys,
so I'm Justin Haugh.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I'm
Guido van Rossum.
JUSTIN HAUGH: And we're here
to talk to you guys about
scaling AppEngine
applications.
There's the right button.
So I'm a software engineer on
the AppEngine team, I work on
system infrastructure.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I'm also a
software engineer on the
AppEngine team.
I work on tools and run times
and everything Python related.
And here's a bunch of links that
you probably won't have
time to type in to
your computer.
JUSTIN HAUGH: But yeah, there's
a feedback link if
you'd like to give us some
feedback throughout the talk.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: And it's
an AppEngine app.
JUSTIN HAUGH: Which
means it scales.
OK so here's the agenda
for today.
We're going to be talking about
scaling on AppEngine.
I'll start off by telling you
a little bit about the
AppEngine platform,
what is scaling?
Is scaling actually
a hard problem?
I'm guessing because of this
audience that it probably is.
And then talk about the
scaling formula
that AppEngine uses.
And then Guido will be talking
about how to build a scalable
application on AppEngine, I
going into some tools advice,
some pitfalls to avoid and then
we'll wrap up with Q&A.
so
So why do we care
about scaling?
I think it's interesting to go
back and look at the first
AppEngine blog post
back in 2008.
"The goal is to make it easy to
scale and get started with
the new web app, and then make
it easy to scale when that app
reaches the point where it's
receiving significant traffic
and has millions of users."
And that's still
our goal today.
We want AppEngine to be a really
high performance and
scalable web framework
for you guys to use.
So what is scaling?
It means handling very high
levels of QPS with low latency
and few or no errors.
This leads to happy users,
happy engineers, happy
investors and that's what we're
all looking for here.
So QPS, that's queries per
second, we use that term a
lot, it's in the admin
console when you go
and work with AppEngine.
Latency, we're referring to the
time it takes to handle a
request. With errors we're
talking about HTTP response
code, so 500 plus you consider
a scaling error.
And then if you think about
numbers, what constitutes a
very high traffic app that
needs to scale well?
A query per second, I mean if
you actually just upload an
app to AppEngine and you are
getting a query per second
that's actually pretty good
traffic, but that's not really
that hard to achieve in
terms of scalability.
When you're starting to get to
100 QPS, 1000 QPS, that's an
app that needs to scale.
When you're talking about 10,000
or more, that's a very
impressive application that's
getting a lot of traffic.
It needs to be really well
architected and needs to use a
lot of the techniques that Guido
will be talking about.
So an example of a scalable app
that's currently running
on AppEngine is Panoramio.
This is an application that
allows you to kind of take
your lens, it's like a way to go
look at photos that people
have shared around the world.
It's actually a Google
application
that runs on AppEngine.
So they get about 2000
QPS at their peak.
Nice traffic curve there,
that's four
days' worth of traffic.
If you look at the breakdown of
there traffic, most of that
is a dynamic request that's been
served by AppEngine, some
of it is cached, and their
latency is very low and
constant, so this is an example
of an app that's doing
a really great job
using AppEngine.
This is their errors, so this
is about between 8 and 30
errors per second.
This is actually really
low, this is
like .01% of the traffic.
So this is a really high
performance app that is really
showing what you can
do with AppEngine.
So is scaling hard?
There's two schools of
thought about this.
I would say, to some extent,
the answer's no.
Most programs are actually
really scalable.
If you just have a simple
website, if you're just
serving static content, if
you're reading and writing a
few form fields on a request,
that's actually
really easy to do.
If you just upload that to
AppEngine it'll most likely
scale really well out the box.
But when you get to more
interesting programs that are
doing aggregations, data joins,
fan-ins, fan-outs, if
you're working with complex data
structures, if you are
working with large amounts of
data, audio, video, images
these things are potential
bottlenecks in your
application, and you need to be
careful about how you are
using these things
to scale well.
And so the truth is
that it depends.
It depends on the problem
you're solving.
It depends on the infrastructure
you're using.
If you're using your laptop,
obviously you're going to have
some limits even if it's
a very well designed
application.
If you have a rack of machines
that you're managing, if you
want to scale up you have to
go buy a computer, plug it
into the rack.
If you're on a scalable cloud
like AppEngine, things get a
lot easier.
We'll talk about
how that works.
And of course it depends on how
much time and money you
want to throw the problem.
So efficient scaling is what
we're talking about.
But programs are
born scalable.
Hello World is a really scalable
app on AppEngine.
You can get extremely high QPS
levels out of Hello World
without a lot of work.
But adding things makes
them less scalable.
So reading and writing data,
making HTTP requests, large
requests and responses, again
large amounts of data, can
slow you down.
Really this is the interesting
work that most applications
are doing, so we'll be talking
about strategies to avoid
these potential hot spots.
So caching parallel, do things
in parallel using async APIs,
or threading, can you
do things offline?
These are things that you should
be thinking about as
your application starts
to get more complex.
So let's talk about
the AppEngine
platform and how it works.
So AppEngine's all HTTP
based, everything is
based around requests.
We have the concept of app
instances, so you upload your
app to tap AppEngine you just
write some code, hit upload
and it's there, it's deployed.
And each instance of your
application is a process that
can handle any number
of requests.
So python processes are single
threaded, and handle requests
one after the other in serial.
Java just recently added
multithreaded support as of
1.4.3 and this allows Java to
handle requests in parallel if
you enable it.
AppEngine performs
dynamic scaling.
So you actually don't use any
instances that would take up
any space in AppEngine if you're
not getting traffic.
And as your traffic starts to
rise we just automatically are
creating instances for you based
on a scaling protocol.
So we look at a lot of
variables, perform a
calculation, and then if your
traffic levels of are starting
to increase, we'll add
some more instances.
So we'll go into a little
more detail about that.
And our platform both are to
minimize your latency of the
requests that are coming in
before they get handled by an
instance, minimize the number
of instances, and then have
very high utilization
of those.
So the scaling formula.
Whenever you get a request,
whenever a request arrives at
AppEngine, it actually doesn't
immediately get
handled by an instance.
It waits for a short period of
time in a pending queue.
And this is in contrast to
some more traditional
architectures, where requests
are immediately routed to a
machine or a server.
So AppEngine has to
make a decision.
It has to decide how long to
wait, and what to do with that
request. Should it give it
to any existing instance?
Or should it create
a new instance?
So the inputs to this formula
are: the number of instances
that you currently have, the
throughput of those instances,
and the number of requests
that are waiting in the
fitting queue in order
to be served.
And when I say waiting, we're
talking on the order of less
than a second.
Less than 100 milliseconds.
And so AppEngine will make a
prediction based on these
variables of how long requests
are going to have to wait in
order to be handled by one of
these existing instances, and
if that prediction is too long
we'll create a new instance.
So there's a comparison to the
loading time, and you can see
some sample code that
gives you the
idea of how that works.
So let's walk you through
a quick example.
So let's say you have an
application that has about 100
milliseconds of latency once
it handles a request. But
creating a new instance
takes a second.
So AppEngine is tracking these
variables for this
application.
And let's say there's five
instances already.
So, in the first case, let's say
there's ten requests that
are sitting in the pending queue
that have just arrived.
The wait time to handle those
requests for the next request
that comes in that queue, it'll
have to wait about 200
milliseconds.
AppEngine knows this because
it's looking at your latency.
So it's going to wait.
It's going to not load a new
instance because it would take
a second to load up
that instance.
So it's faster just to wait.
And so that's the result.
In the other case, let's take
another example where 100
requests are sitting in
the pending queue.
The next request that comes in
would have to wait two seconds
for those five instances to
churn through the request
queue in order to handle that
request. So in this case the
results of the algorithm is
to create a new instance.
So you can see how this works.
But there's actually a little
more detail to it.
It's not enough just to compare
the loading time and
the waiting time.
We also need to calculate and to
take into account the warm
latency, the latency of how
long it takes to handle a
request once your instance
is ready to go.
And in this case it was about
100 milliseconds.
We actually would more
aggressively create new
instances for this application
if the pending time started to
get large in comparison to
the warm request latency.
AppEngine doesn't want to be the
cause of your latency, so
we do what we can't to increase
your instance count
and scale you up.
So in steady state, there's
going to be a certain
percentage of your instances
that are idle, as they finish
a request, wait for a short
period of time for a new
request to come off
the pending queue.
But the waiting time is going to
be very small in comparison
to your latency.
But this is a dynamic process
and new requests are coming in
all the time.
Instances may have to be turned
down if they have an
error or they exceed a certain
number of requests to be
handled overtime.
So things are always in flux.
So AppEngine is doing what it
can to really optimize your
performance and also
your utilisation.
Warmup requests are something
I'd also highlight here.
Warm up requests allow AppEngine
to create new
instances in the background
without actually handling a
user request. And so users will
never see the latency
that would result from loading
up a new instance due to a
warmup request. So you can
enable this in your app.yaml
in Python, there's also a Java
version equivalent, by adding
in-bound services warm up.
So how quickly can your
app scale up?
You know you've got a big
mention on Tech Crunch, you're
getting a ton of traffic.
It depends on your latency.
And these are some guidelines
I would give you guys.
If you latency is about 100
milliseconds this is
excellent, you're doing
really well.
If your latency is 250
milliseconds, that's OK.
When you start to get a second
or higher, AppEngine is going
to be a little more conservative
about giving you
new instances, because your
application is not performing
quite quickly enough.
And it also depends on
your loading time.
So if you're less than a second
that's a pretty good
loading time.
AppEngine will be willing to
load up new instances.
Anything longer than that starts
to slow things down.
And so what we're talking about
in this section of the
talk is the velocity of adding
and handling more queries per
second, so let's say your
traffic goes from 0 to 10 QPS
for let's say a 200 millisecond
application, you
can you scale very quickly
in about a second.
When you get to 100 QPS
you're talking just
maybe about ten seconds.
When you talk about 1000 QPS,
that's quite a lot of traffic,
AppEngine needs a little bit
of time to react to that.
And because throughput is so
important, I just wanted to
contrast single threaded and
the multi-threaded case.
So in the single threaded case,
your run times are only
handling one request
at a time.
So the QPS really is almost
entirely determined by the
latency of your application.
You can see some
examples here.
In the multithreaded case, and
again this is new in Java,
that as of 1.4.3 you can mark
your app thread safe and it
can handle multiple requests
at the same time.
So this is a really great way to
make your Java applications
highly scalable and I
recommend you guys
go check this out.
And really at this point your
throughput per instance is
primarily determined by the
amount of CPU usage that
you're doing to handle a
request. AppEngine will
continue to give your
multithreaded instances more
and more requests, as long as
the CPU rate is reasonable.
And I've given some examples
with 2.4 gigahertz processors
which is about what we're
using right now.
And so you can take a look
at the instances console.
This is what a typical
app might look like.
You can see the QPS per
instance, the latency, and you
should go check this console out
pretty regularly to just
see how your instances are
performing, and see if you can
do something to make
them more scalable.
In this example, this app has
enabled always on, and always
on is another thing that you
guys think could enable to
help your apps scale.
Because you'll have three
instances that are always
ready to go at any time.
And I'd recommend you do this
if you are thinking you're
going to expects some
load spikes or
have erratic traffic.
But back to reality,
you know we've gone
through some math here.
How do things work
in real life?
These theoretical limits we've
been talking about, they're
not exactly achievable.
There's routing overhead,
there's load fluctuations,
there's some safety limits that
app engine has in place
to prevent us from just creating
hundreds and hundreds
of new instances in a very
short period of time.
So app engine is a very scalable
platform, it does
need a few seconds, a few
minutes if you're talking
about thousands of QPS.
And we do tweak the formula
regularly, so you make
trade-offs between performance
and utilisation.
Of course we could just throw
more instances at your
application, but that wouldn't
provide very good utilization.
And there's machine upgrades,
infrastructure changes that
are taking place, we introduce
new features like
pre-compilation, warming
requests like always on that
make things scale better.
So just some take aways
I would mention.
AppEngine does a lot for you.
It tracks your latency, your
CPU, it's a scalable cloud
platform that's always adding
and removing instances.
It's trying to optimize both
performance and utilization.
And it responds very quickly
to traffic spikes.
But it doesn't understand where
your latencies comes
from, it doesn't understand
where your CP usage is coming
from, it he can't make your
app more performing.
So Guido will be talking a
little bit about that in a
second, but you know it's really
a partnership between
you and AppEngine.
And just as an example, here's
a successful partnership.
This is Matt Mastracci of gri.pe
and he just sent us an
e-mail last November, saying
just wanted to say thanks for
making a great product, they got
mentioned on "The View",
resulted in a lot of traffic,
it looks like they got up to
about 300 QPS.
AppEngine scaled wonderfully, we
got about 900 errors on the
front page while it scaled up,
but compared to the overall
traffic that was nothing.
Our app has seen a ton of
traffic but it's amazingly
fast, you wouldn't even know.
And I think this really
shows like how
AppEngine typically works.
We didn't do anything
special for Matt.
He's just a typical user.
So with that I'll turn it over
to Guido, to talk about how to
build a scalable app.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Thank
you Justin.
[APPLAUSE]
So now that Justin has discussed
some of the theory
behind AppEngine scaling, I'm
going to discuss what you
actually have to do to make
your apps scale as well as
that successful gri.pe
application.
So there are some techniques
and tools that I want to
discuss, beginning with loading
testing and then
focusing a little bit bit on
something called Appstats.
But before I even start this, I
want to mention that always
you have to treat this as sort
of experimental science.
You're looking at a very
complicated system, it behaves
a certain way, you have to
really poke and prod it in
various ways to find out
how it really behaves.
Which is often sort
of unintuitive.
You you might not actually
understand the performance
characteristics of your own
application, even if you wrote
the code yourself.
At least that is my personal
experience.
Even so, whatever you learn
today might not be valid
tomorrow, or next week
or next year.
Because your users change.
Maybe they become more
sophisticated, maybe you
attract different types of
users, also of course your
application changes.
And it's very likely that when
you add the new feature in
this part of your application,
somehow it effects the
performance of some other part
of your application that you
didn't think was affected
by that feature at all.
Also as data accumulates in the
AppEngine data store, the
performance characteristics
of the data
store may change somewhat.
And of course AppEngine
itself changes.
I mean it's a very complicated
production environment, the
sort of the network weather
varies by day and by week.
Also the AppEngine team always
make improvements, as Justin
mentioned, that complex scaling
formula is regularly
tweaked and tunes and
sort of adjusted.
And in general we do
that to make sure
your apps scale better.
But sometimes we make changes
that like work out one way for
90% of the apps and work out a
slightly less positive way for
some other apps.
So, sort of be aware, even if
you think you know exactly,
you understand the performance
of your app, it may change.
So keep an eye on it.
So the most important technique
that I recommend
that anybody who is expecting
or even hoping to reach a
significant number of QPS, you
have to do this basically.
Run a synthetic load test. There
are many tools to sort
of aid you in load testing
that can send synthetic
traffic to your site from some
other system that is outside
AppEngine or sometimes
some tools
actually run on AppEngine.
And the important reason to
actually try your app with
synthetic traffic is that when
you when you didn't do this,
and you hit a sort of sudden
success with live traffic,
it's too late to fix things or
it's a mad scramble to figure
out what went wrong.
And the thing is, in practice
you almost always hit a bump
if you didn't actually
plan and test.
So the basic approach
for load testing is
actually fairly simple.
You sort, of using the one of
these tools to generate
synthetic traffic, you generally
increase your
traffic that your application
receives.
And I would recommend using a
test instance or at least a
test version of the application
if you've already
gone live for a smaller
number of users.
So you increase your
traffic basically
until you hit a bump.
That bump can be that your
application suddenly starts
return much higher
error rates.
Or it just sort of starts
responding slower and slower.
Those two are actually
pretty related.
Or your load testing tool finds
out that it cannot drive
traffic at the site faster
than a certain QPS.
That is the point where you're
going to, unless you say OK
I'm really happy with 20 QPS,
that's all I want to shoot
for, but in general you probably
hit the bottle neck
and you want to get
beyond that point.
So now you use some other
tools, and there's the
AppEngine dashboard, the whole
admin console has a number of
different tools just
already showed up.
The instances console, there's
a whole bunch of different
charts of performance over
time that you can use.
The logs are a very important
tool, also the quoted details
help you understand
what is going on.
How much how much of each
type of resource
your application uses.
And then there's Appstats which
we will get to it in a
few slides.
Using all those tools together,
you have to actually
sort of perform science and
reasoning and logic about your
application as if it's a black
box and you don't understand
exactly how it works, until
you understand why it is
hitting this bump.
Is it a data store problem?
Is your cache not operating
correctly?
Are you're spending too much
time expanding the template?
Are you hanging on some
external URL?
There are many possible
reasons.
So once you understand what's
going in your application, you
produce a fix.
You rewrite some small section
of code-- hopefully it's a
small section--
fine tune something, change some
configuration, redeploy
and then you go at it again.
It's just a rinse and repeat
approach and hopefully now
you'll get a little higher.
And then probably, if you keep
driving more and more traffic
at as your application, it is
very likely that you'll hit
another bump in a different part
of your application or a
different part of the
infrastructure.
You learn a lot about AppEngine
this way, and you
learn a lot about sort of
performance tuning in general
and about your particular
app in specific.
And hopefully you will
eventually reach sort of a
smooth trajectory where you can
handle many 100s of QPS or
whatever your traffic
projections are.
So there are a number of things
that I want to sort of
remind you of doing.
Justin already explained that
the complex scaling formula is
very nice but it sort of
generates instances gradually.
So don't run a load test where
you start driving 200 QPS at
an app that was dormant before
that, and run that for half a
minute and see how it performs.
Because during that
half minute all you will see is
errors while some instances
are being created but not
enough to actually
deal with the queue.
Gradually increase your traffic,
so take like three or
five minutes or so to reach
100 or 200 QPS.
Then let it run for
a little while.
So that you can actually observe
the application in its
ideal steady state.
Another thing I want to
emphasize is, it's very easy
to sort of hit one URL with any
of the load testing tools
or performance testing tools.
That may not actually be how
your users are going to use
that application.
One technique that I like is
invite a bunch of friends to
use the application, and sort
of just record what they do.
Keep track of exactly which
URLs they hit, what their
behavior is.
You can use the logs, it's
pretty easy to sort of figure
out on the logs which part
belongs to which user.
And so if you do this at a very
small scale but enough to
have some idea of what users do,
and those sessions you can
then use to sort of tell your
load testing what kind of
traffic to drive at
your application.
Like so many hits of the home
page, so many hits of the
preferences page,
this and that.
Make sure to also include static
resources like style
sheets or images,
what have you.
Also take into account that
there's a certain amount of
client caching.
Although if you expect thousands
of different users,
of course each of those users
is going to request every
static resource that you have
on your home page at least
once, so sort of think about all
those things to create a
realistic synthetic
traffic pattern.
Because I've seen some people
very disappointed because they
had a load test that proved
that they could handle 500
QPS, and them on the actual
users came along they had a
bump at 100 QPS.
Because the users were doing
very different things than the
load test was testing.
Also another thing is sometimes
load testing tools
themselves have an obvious
sort of limitation.
One obvious limitation is of
course is if the load test,
the load generating tool runs
on a machine that has
relatively low network
bandwidth, because then it
can't actually drive a very
significant amount of traffic.
Anyway load testing can
be a lot of fun.
Do it.
Get good at load testing before
you sort of announce
your first app to
the wide public.
It's much better than
having to scramble
once your load comes.
So one important tool that I
want to call out at least a
little bit at this point,
because it's so incredibly
useful both for debugging apps
in general and for developing
performance like doing
a load test in
particular, is Appstats.
Appstats is a tool that--
actually I gave a talk about
Appstats about a year ago--
so I'm not going to say a whole
lot about it because you
can still find that talk on the
web, search for Appstats
or Appstats AppEngine or
something and you'll find it.
So Appstats is based on the
theory that most likely if you
have an app that doesn't perform
adequately or that
hits some kind of performance
bump, as you try to scale it,
the most likely reason is
something to do with remote
procedure calls.
Now in AppEngine everything you
do with the data store,
with Memcache, fetching external
URLs, everything like
that is actually an RPC.
Traditional CPU based profiling
just counts function
calls and times them and doesn't
give you very good
information about what
those RPCs are.
Appstats focuses entirely on the
RPCs, collects information
about every RPCs made you during
a request, and then
visualizes that in very sort
of in your face ways.
So it's completely obvious what
your request is doing,
and often then it's also
completely obvious why it's
not performing the way you
thought it should be.
And this tool exists both
for Python and Java.
So the only other thing I want
to say about Appstats, this is
the kind of chart you
get out of Appstats.
This is a very simple time
line , each box here
represents one RPC, so you can
see that here was a data store
that called for some reason 247
milliseconds, so that's
interesting I would say.
So what you can is you can click
on this box, now this is
not a live demo so I'm not going
to show that, but you
can click on that box and it
will, somewhere here below, it
will expand to a stack trace
where you can see exactly
which sequence of function
calls led up to that
particular RPC call.
And at least if you're using
the Python version, you can
also inspect the contents of
each stack frame so you'll see
the local variables and
parameters that will pass into
these functions.
So if you Appstats shows that
you're making three queries
like in this case, or three
queries in a row and you sort
of thinking about what that
request did, you were only
expecting it would make one
query, you can immediately
find out where those other
two queries come from.
And maybe they're totally
expected once
you understand that.
This is an incredible eye
opener, so go download--
you don't actually have to
download it, it's included in
the standard SDK and also
in the run time.
So now that we've sort of
discussed the science of
measuring what's going on in
your app, by sort of using
either a telescope or a
microscope, look at your app,
what things can you do to make
your application work better?
What what sort of typical
techniques can you use to
solve the problems that
you found using or
doing a load test?
Now there are lots
of strategies.
One strategy I would sort of
summarize as stupid schema
tricks, the AppEngine data
store is not a relational
database and there are a bunch
of things you can do.
Given the focus on RPCs, the
fact that too many RPCs is so
often a cause of slowness in
your application, batching
RPCs together is an important
technique to save on latency.
There's also something called
parallel RPCs where you don't
reduce the number of RPCs, but
you reduce the time that you
wait for them.
And finally of course there's
lots of different places in
applications and on the Internet
where you can tune
your caching.
So let's look at each of these
in a little more detail.
So stupid schema tricks.
Basically and there have been
many talks and blog posts and
articles about this, so I don't
have to explain much of
this, but AppEngine's data
store is not a relational
database, it is not SQL.
And some of the things that
are sort of dogma with SQL
actually work counter productive
in AppEngine.
For one example is, in SQL if
you have a table with lots of
columns, and you query against
some of those columns, the
data that it is in columns that
you're not looking at is
never actually fetched.
Well in AppEngine it works
slightly different.
All the data that it is
in a particular row--
if I can sort of carry over
that SQL terminology--
is actually fetched into
your application.
So if you search for certain
columns, all the data that is
in other columns for the same
record will still be fetched
to application.
If you have something like
a photo application that
contains there's a large blob
of jpeg data that you don't
use except when you want to
display the image of course,
you would still be paying for
fetching that as part of your
query results.
So a very simple solution here
is to break up that particular
table or entity kind
as we called it in
AppEngine, into two parts.
For example the photo metadata,
which would be a
small entity with just the
columns that describe things
like date the picture
was taken, title,
file names, so on.
And a separate entity containing
the large bulky
data, like the image, there may
be a thumbnail and some
other things.
So now your query results come
in much faster because that
bulk data doesn't have to
push through the client.
Pretty much the opposite is sort
of duplicating data in
multiple entities.
This is basically sort of going
against the SQL dogma of
normalize your schema.
There are many situations in
AppEngine where it's actually
useful to actually make
redundant copies of a certain
piece of information in a couple
of different entities
that you then all have to update
at once, in order to
make reading those entities more
efficient, in the sense
that you only need one of those
entities in order to be
able to display the
information.
You don't have to sort of
do pointer chasing.
Because pointer chasing, which
in the AppEngine data store
turns into reference chasing,
every time you chase one of
those references is another
RPC that gets very costly.
So batching, it's a very
simple concept.
If you're somehow in a loop, or
maybe that loop is sort of
hidden in your code, if you are
fetching a whole bunch of
different entities or maybe
you writing a bunch of
different entities, one entity
at a time, you pay RPC
overhead for each entity
you read and write.
And given that all this goes
across various networking
nodes, and there's some access
control checking going on, and
various bits of overhead, the
cost of an RPC is sort of the
cost that it takes to do the
actual work, like find the
entity in the data store.
Plus the cost for the network
traffic going back and forth.
And there's a certain amount of
constant cost per RPC that
by combining a whole bunch of
get requests or put requests
in a single call, you
can shave off lots.
So using Appstats I took two
snapshots of a very simple
application, it just fetches
20 different keys using 20
RPCs, and in this case it took
nearly 400 milliseconds
realtime to fetch
those entities.
And then I compared that to a
slight modification of the
same app where it fetches those
same 20 keys using a
single batch RPC.
And here it only takes
200 milliseconds.
So we sort of halved the latency
of the request by
using a batch request. So both
the data store and Memcache
are fairly latency sensitive
in this way.
So you can get a lot of affect
by using the batch APIs and
the data store has a slightly
different style of API use it
has to get a put request, a
list of keys or entities
instead of a single
key or entity.
Memcache has seperate get
and get null calls.
But in both cases the effect
is the same, the more you
batch, the faster it goes.
So parallel RPCs is a
different approach.
Until the AppEngine release
1.5.0 that was released this
very morning, you can't look
at it because the wifi is
pretty much down.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'll tell you, it is out.
Until now the main application
of parallel RPCs was for URL
fetch, which is the AppEngine
specific interface for going
out on the web and fetching
something from another server
that is not in Google
data center.
Or maybe it is in Google
And since an external server
easily takes 200, 300
milliseconds or a second or so
for a round trip, if you have
to fetch more than one external
RPC, that could
really slow you down.
So I think about two years
ago, we had a separate
asynchronous API to URL fetch
where you can sort of say, go
fetch this one, go fetch this
one, go fetch this one, and
then wait for all of them.
Again here is a little example
chart taken with Appstats
where you see the dramatic
difference between doing those
URL fetches in series
or in parallel.
So the new thing in 1.5.0
is there are separate
asynchronous calls for data
store get, put, and delete.
Which are the most important
ones for
which this makes sense.
So you can start a series of
gets and a series of puts
simultaneously, those gets
async or put async calls
return something called
an RPC handle.
So they return immediately,
they, in the background, start
sending the stuff to the data
store and the data store
starts doing the work.
And then when your application
is ready to consume the
results it can call get result
on the handle and then it will
get the same results as the
corresponding synchronous call
would have returned.
The advantage here again is that
you can make a bunch of
these calls in parallel, set up
a bunch of gets and puts.
In the future you will even get
be able to set up multiple
independent transactions.
And your total wait time is
equal to sort of the slowest
of all the RPCs rather than
the sum of all the RPCs.
So the more you parallelize
the more you win.
And you can do this in Java too,
Google for get async data
store service to find the proper
documentation for that.
So the last sort of standard
technique that everybody needs
to know about and hopefully
you have heard
about it, is caching.
So there are actually lots
of different places
where you can cache.
This is a tiny little diagram
of how requests travel from
the browser to your application
to the data store
and then the data comes back.
So the question is where can
you where put in caching?
Well it turns out there
is actually catching
opportunities in every
one of these boxes.
So let's look at
the first one.
In the browser, closest to the
user, the browser caches
stuff, how much the browser
caches depend on various HTTP
headers and the most recommended
header at this
point is cache control.
There's also something called
Etags which is sort of an
additional thing.
And then there's expires but
that's pretty much sort of
replaced by cache control.
So if you only want status to
be cached in the browser for
various privacy reasons you can
set cache control private
and then you set a max age.
Now the problem with the max age
is, if you set it too low,
the cache is not
very effective.
If you set it too high, the
cache is more effective but
there's also a probability
that the users
will see stale data.
Because the browser really sort
of holds on to that data
in its cache very effectively.
So what's a good number
for max age?
Of course that depends
on your application.
But basically this
is a problem.
So there's a different place
where you can ask for caching
and in many cases it will
actually work, and that is
sort of on the Internet.
And now you can--
companies run proxy servers
and ISPs often also run
Internet caches.
So that popular content, this
is most effective if you're
doing something really high
visibility, really high QPS.
Like say you're planning some
kind of royal wedding, the
nice thing here is even with a
small cache time out, like
setting it to a minute or even
10 seconds sometimes, if there
are enough users that are all
talking to the same cache--
so if the ISP has positioned
their cache
in the right spot--
even such a short caching time
can be very effective.
Because during that minute that
the data is valid in the
cache, hundreds or thousands
of users might actually be
hitting that cache instead of
going all the way to your app.
So your app sees less traffic
and users are happier.
Of course at this point you
have to put public in your
cache control header, because
that cache is shared.
So make sure that you don't
accidentally use this for per
user, or otherwise
sensitive data.
In some cases, Google
itself actually has
a cache like this.
Now I have to it to emphasize
that this is not
a guaranteed service.
And it only work for paid
AppEngine apps, which is good
because if you're a free
AppEngine app you probably
don't have enough traffic to
benefit from this style of
caching anyway.
But there is some caching in
Google's Front End servers.
It's controlled exactly the same
way, just the same cache
control public header, has the
same nice property there s
fairly small time out
on the cache.
It's still sufficient to
get the high benefits.
The nice thing is if it's being
cached in Google, you
will still see this traffic on
the dashboard in the AppEngine
console, and you'll see
it in the logs.
You can recognize it by
the 204 response code.
So that's catching sort
of your application.
Of course you can also put
caches in your application.
And perhaps the simplest place
to put some caching is just in
main memory of your
application.
In Python you just store stuff
in global variables.
Modular global variables.
In Java you use static
variables
for the same purpose.
The upside is that it's really
fast because it works at
memory speeds, like 100
nanoseconds or so.
The downside is of course that
each instance, and we're
assuming here that your
application's getting enough
traffic that there are multiple
instances, has its
own copy of the data.
So if it takes a lot of effort
to compute that data, each
instance recomputes that data
when it starts up, or when it
first needs it.
And you'd better only use this
for data that essentially
never changes, because it
changes in one instance,
there's no effective way for
that instance to communicate
to the other instances
that what it is
caching is now invalid.
So that's a natural segue
to using Memcache.
Which is a separate service,
that even though it's called
Memcache, it doesn't use your
application's memory, it uses
a separate server's memory.
However because it just
stores the data in
that server's memory--
that server has like, oh I don't
know, 16GB of RAM or
something, or 32 or 64--
that's shared between different
AppEngine apps.
But basically with like a
latency of one millisecond or
a few milliseconds, Memcache
stores one consistent copy
that can be accessed by every
instance of your app very
effectively.
Of course this is not
persistent, so don't use this
as a sort of substitute
for the datastore.
I also want to mention
something
called dog pile effect.
There are situations in
production where temporarily
the memcache service
is unavailable.
I mean there are other
situations where it just sort
of expires data before you say
it should be expired, but
sometimes it's unavailable.
And then if all your instances
go to the data store, instead
they might actually overwhelm
the data store.
So there's some tricks with time
outs and keep trying not
to overwhelm the data store.
The best thing to do if you want
to learn more about that
is just Google for
dog pile effect.
So there's one final spot where
it actually sometimes
make sense to cache stuff, and
this might be a bit sort of
unintuitive.
You can actually use the
data store as a cache.
A nice example is Nick Johnson
Bloggart application which is
a very simple blog
management app.
And basically what he does is,
whenever you create a new blog
page for when you update an
existing blog page, he
pre-renders the sort of
resulting output, which is
probably composed from the blog
entry and info about the
author and info about
other blog entries.
He sort of pregenerates all
that and stores the fully
generated page in
the data store.
So when a page is requested,
when users are viewing the
blog pages, it's a single
datastore store request. It
just fetches the pre-rendered
page and returns it without
any sort of processing.
And that way he claims that
they can do sort of 50
millisecond latency which is a
very nice number I would say.
So, we're going to cut the
Q&A time a little short
unfortunately, fortunately
there's a lunch break right
after this.
So there are certain things that
I've seen a lot of people
make mistakes with, and in
general AppEngine team has
some experience with what
typical user mistakes are.
There's a bunch of programming
bugs that I actually discussed
in my Appstats talk last year.
So search for the Appstats
video from last year.
I want to call up out two
specific things, and there are
also blogs about these so I
don't have to explain in too
much detail.
The first one is entity
contention.
When you're writing this same
entity or the same entity
group if you're using
transactions, the data store
is actually limited to, let's
say one write per second.
I think the data store team will
say, well in practice, we
sometimes support a little more
than one write per second
but not a whole lot.
So clearly if you're keeping
sort of a global counter of
how many requests have been
made to your service.
It's not a good idea to store
that counter in data store in
a simplistic way, because you
would be limiting your QPS to
about one request per second.
This problem has been known for
a long time and there's a
fairly straightforward
solution for it.
Just search for shard
encounters.
And if you actually do the
search right you'll also see
some alternatives that actually
don't shard but but
use various useful
approximations.
Finally, another thing that can
happen in the data store,
is if you append data with a
sequential increasing key, or
actually also same problem if
you're using index property
value, if you sort of append to
the end of the sequence of
data, all that data goes
to the same thing
called a tablet server.
And if you want to understand
more about tablet servers, go
to the talk called "More Nines
Please." I believe it's
tomorrow morning.
It explains a lot more about how
the AppEngine data store
works and what kind of things
we've done in the last six
months or so to make
it work better.
So anyway, the problem with
sequentially appending data
that has predictable keys like
this, is that all your data
always goes to the last tablet
that is assigned to a
particular entity
kind or table.
And normally tablets when they
get too full or too busy they
split up and they sort of
distribute the range of keys
that they handle in two.
But because of the append
behavior of the application,
that doesn't actually help.
And no matter how often you
split that last tablet, all
the data will always go to the
last tablet in your list of
tablets for your data.
And now tablet servers
are also limited.
I do not know exactly what the
right value for n is and it
probably varies a bit on the
exact properties of the data,
but let's say 10 or 20
writes per second.
So again that would sort
of limit your QPS
to a sadly low number.
Or what it will do is you'll
get lots of data store time
outs and application errors.
So what you have to do is
randomize your data.
And sometimes you don't have
to do something very
sophisticated.
Just using the user name or
something is often enough to
avoid this hot tablet issue.
If you want to learn more about
this, go to Ikai Lan's
blog, he's one of our developer
relationships people.
He has a blog called Ikai Lan
Says and he has actually
drawing skills that greatly
surpass mine, so he has a
bunch of very entertaining
cartoons that explain how sort
of the tablet splitting works
under good circumstances and
under not so good
circumstances.
So all I have left is a little
summary of what we've learned
today, app engine scales that
can support many thousands of
QPS, but to get to that
point you still
have to do some work.
You have to understand your
application and tune in and
load test it.
And one of the reasons is that
sort of new instances are
created gradually, and sort of
in order to optimally create
new instances, the request
latency, how long it takes to
execute one request,
is the key factor.
So treat your performance
to tuning as a science.
We discussed some tools, some
techniques, a bunch of
approaches for speeding up
applications, a whole bunch of
different places where
you can do caching.
And we discussed some
common bottlenecks.
And well here are some links,
and now maybe we do have
enough time, and if people want
to ask questions, please
use the microphone.
And we'll both be available
for answering questions.
[APPLAUSE]
JUSTIN HAUGH: Go ahead.
MATT MASTRACCI: Hi I'm
Matt Mastracci
from gri.pe, actually.
We do a lot of continuous
integration, and I was just
wondering how instance scaling
works when you push a new
instance of your app?
Because we push probably
20 to 30 times a day.
I guess how are new instances
scaled around the
times when we push?
JUSTIN HAUGH: Is this
mike still on?
We can hear you.
JUSTIN HAUGH: When you deploy
a new version of your
application or you do an update,
AppEngine remembers
quite a lot about--
okay, is the mike not working?
So AppEngine remembers--
hello, is this working?
So AppEngine remembers when
you deploy a new version,
quite a lot about the previous
versions's scale and its
performance characteristics,
and so generally speaking
that's usually pretty
seamless.
It doesn't suffer the same sort
of gradual ramp up effect
that you would normally
expect.
MATT MASTRACCI: Thank you.
JUSTIN HAUGH: Thanks
for your quote.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Over there?
ALBERT WONG: Hello, my
name's Albert Wong.
I saw that Go was offered
as a language for
AppEngine on the page.
Would Go allow you to
have multithreaded
applications also?
JUSTIN HAUGH: That's a question
for the Go team, I
think I'll probably
defer it to them.
ALBERT WONG: Is there going
to be a talk on that?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Yeah there is
today, it was like at this
very same time slot in
a different room.
[LAUGHTER]
Sorry.
JUSTIN HAUGH: But if I could
just speak for them, I would I
guess with high probability
the answer is yes.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: Yeah, Go has
sort of built in concurrency
support and they would be crazy
not to turn that on.
It's new for us too, so we don't
have much experience
with it yet.
JUSTIN HAUGH: Question
over here?
Uh yeah, you mentioned for
concurrency support on Python,
is that something that's going
to come in the future?
Beause I guess for someone
who's starting off with a
brand new app, would you say in
terms of scalability would
Java in fact give you more power
in the sense that it has
that threading support
on AppEngine?
JUSTIN HAUGH: I can speak
to that for just a sec.
We do have some plans around
Python concurrency, they're
not ready to be announced.
But Python is quite scalable,
we see some apps that get a
lot of traffic with Python.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I would say
that other things to do
consider besides the concurrency
is that often a
Python app uses less memory than
a similar Java app and it
also starts up faster, so
instance creation latency is
much lower for typical
Python apps.
And again that is sort of data
that is valid today, I don't
know how valid that will
be six months from now.
JUSTIN HAUGH: One one other
thing I would just mention is
that the load time of your
application really does matter
quite a lot.
And Java does have a little bit
of a longer start up time.
Python starts very quickly.
I'm Craig [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I guess one thing I'd mention on
the concurrency thing is no
GS is single threaded, so it's
a pretty good at handling a
lot of requests for server.
My question is that you
mentioned a test instance.
I was wondering is there a way
to create a test instance,
with a test copy of data that
you can write to but not
affect the production data?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: I would
recommend just copying being
your production data using the
bulk loader, so you just
download a copy of your data
using the bulk loader, to your
own workstation and then
you upload that to a
different app instance.
So you'd have to create two app
instances, and you can't
do that with a test version, but
if you create a separate
test app instance with just a
different app ID, you can just
upload your production
data there.
Great, thank you.
Hi, I'm [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
I was wondering, can you share
a little bit more detail of
your formula?
So are you using some kind of
dynamic programming approach
or are you doing some kind
of prediction under QPS?
And specifically what I want
to know is whether this
formula, whether
it's a [? VP ?]
or not?
Does it apply per application
or for all applications?
JUSTIN HAUGH: It's
per application.
It's actually per version
of your application.
So you can actually have
multiple versions live at the
same time that are all receiving
traffic and each one
is evaluated independently
for its performance
characteristics.
And then the last question.
Did you consider having some
kind of an API where the
application can give
you the hints?
JUSTIN HAUGH: We do have some
thoughts around that.
Nothing right now.
Introducing some more controls
around certain scaling
variables or the way the formula
works is something
that we've been thinking
about.
For instance, allowing,
for example, when your
application--
when an instance has been
sitting idle for a while when
traffic comes down, the
determination of when to turn
that instance down, that's
example something that we
might give control over.
Thank you.
With regards to Memcache,
how are you handling key
distribution and how durable
are the instances?
Like if one goes down, and how
often do they go down?
Do you lose all your keys
or is that distributed?
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: It's
a hash table.
When the Memcache server
assigned to your app goes
down, you do lose all your keys.
so that's why I put in
that warning.
There's a talk tomorrow about
life in Google AppEngine
production I believe
where they go into
a little more detail.
But basically model you need
to think about is that each
application typically uses one
specific Memcache server,
which is shared with
other applications.
And the Memcache server tries
to give each app its fair
share of key and data space.
It does somewhat penalize
applications that use their
cache inefficiently.
Like if you have very few cache
hits I think it might
evict your data a little sooner
than when you're really
good at cache hits.
Thank you.
My question is tangentially
related to scaling because I'm
finding myself having to create
a lot of reports that
are generated basically by my
app's own data but aren't from
a browser-based client.
And so I've read up on the
Mapper API and some other ways
to kind of get around my own
mental limitations of big
table versus SQL and some smart
ways to do that with
tasks queues and whatnot.
But when I look at the data and
the kinds of information
I'm trying to pull out, it's
essentially a replication of
the kinds of things I would get
if it were a browser-based
client running on Google
Analytics.
So my question to you is, are
there any plans or any thought
or anything in the roadmap
to try to get server-side
analytics in a nice
clean package?
JUSTIN HAUGH: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Come to the next talk.
Thank you.
I'm curious if you guys
have any per user
throttling in the system?
I've been using BulkLoader to
try and download all of our
app's data.
We only have severals gigs of
data, but it still takes eight
hours plus.
So I'm wondering if I'm being
throttled on a per user basis
or if it's just something
in the BulkLoader side.
JUSTIN HAUGH: I don't have that
much familiarity with the
BulkLoader but I do know that it
does have some performance
bottlenecks.
Because it's generally
considered an offline process
so it's not something we're
focusing too much thought into
making that very, very
fast all the time.
But that is something we're
aware of and I think--
Is there anything
on the server?
Then there's nothing on the
server side that's actually
intentionally throttling a user
to be like, ah, you're
hitting the server too much?
That's possibly malicious
and--
JUSTIN HAUGH: I don't think so.
Yeah.
GUIDO VAN ROSSUM: One thing you
mentioned was that it's
considered an offline process.
So it may end up being treated
at a lower priority.
It's also quite possible that
your bulk loading is throttled
by some limitation on bandwidth
on the network
between where you run the bulk
loader client and our
infrastructure.
Also the bulk loader actually
has a bunch of tuning
parameters, if you haven't
already looked into those I
would definitely
recommend that.
You're welcome.
JUSTIN HAUGH: Any
more questions?
All right, thanks everybody, and
we'll be around afterward.